[Music] all of us here at the show are big fans of course of Nick Offerman who plays Ron Swanson on the show Carson yeah great great accurate riffing man well we just found out that in addition to acting Nick is passionate about two other things working outside with his hands and reading tweets from young female celebrities so here is Nick combining both of these passions in a new segment we're calling Nick Offerman from Parks and Recreation reads tweets from young female celebrity celebrity Taylor Swift tweeted in my hotel room youtubing adorable things iCarly start wit 'add all my favorite people are getting new puppies Selena Gomez tweeted about to have a crazy Sox party Miley Cyrus tweeted can't stop eating walnuts ashley tisdale from the suite life of zack & cody tweeted cardio and then yoga i am gonna be sore [Music] [Applause] female celebrities Thank You NIC guys fantastic it's great